these paris airport workers say that
they're overworked and overwhelmed and
they're on strike to demand better pay
and working conditions
it's a vicious circle the bosses cut
staff during the pandemic but salaries
are so low that they're unable to
recruit people so staff now have to cope
with more work as people travel again
it's causing a lot of stress
many workers say they've not had a pay
rise for years and with inflation
they're struggling financially sonya has
worked at ali airport for more than two
decades she says she's been forced to
resort to using food stamps to feed her
children
with inflation being so high in france
petrol is expensive it's just not
possible i can't afford to feed my kids
i can't fill my car i can't take my kids
on a break it's not normal because of
the strike paris airport authorities
have had to cancel one in six flights
for some travellers the reduced flights
mean disruption and longer queues
we came here four hours early as we knew
there was going to be a strike so we
were prepared
on tv i saw that there was an airport
workers strike so i called the airline
as i was worried they'd cancel the
flight but it's okay for now
the protesters say that if their demands
are not met they'll continue their
strike over the next few days as
france's school summer break begins many
people are going on holiday these
workers say they wish they could afford
to do the same natasha butler al jazeera
paris